Let's go to our caller from the 8 3 2. Who's
calling today from 8 3 to.
So easily. Yes, it is. No. Yes.
That's a David. I had a question. I had a
question about popping.
Sorry, your question. Your question was about
what you're breaking up.
My bet, my bet. I don't know if my connection
is good right now, came enough. Yeah, that's
a little better. My bet again, some. Your
question?
Oh, my goodness.
All right. Well, that that one that one's
got. Let's try our caller from the four zero
one area code. Who's calling today from 4
0 1?
I mean, yes, it is.
Favors. David? My question is about the W
H O with Bruce Howard. Have you heard anything
about that?
Is this the. Is this the guy who was asked
about how Taiwan did and he just like. First
he said he couldn't hear the question. Then
he disconnected on Skype. And when they reconnected,
he was like, oh, you already asked me about
that. Ask me about something else.
Yeah, I just wanna hear your thoughts about
that thought.
I mean, listen. It certainly does not inspire
confidence that when we hear from the W.H.O.
how great China's doing, that it's true. Right.
I mean, you know, one of the things we suspected
early on was that China had way more cases
than they were telling the truth about. Eventually,
China claimed to have mitigated the spread.
And one of the things that sort of allayed
our fears that China was lying was that W.H.O.
officials were in the country and they were
saying, no, no, no, China really is doing
that. Well, when then you get a W.H.O. official
who's asked, hey, but how about how Taiwan
did? And the guy first pretends not to hear
the question, then hangs up and then refuses
to answer. It certainly suggests political
bias of the type that makes me question whether
we're getting reliable numbers out of China.
So. So for me, it made me think the problem
maybe has not actually been solved in China.
Yeah, that's right. I've studied Mandarin
Chinese, I've been around a of people while
my whole campus actually have a whole Chinese
part of the campus. And they're all freaked
out about that because a lot of them are from
Taiwan or Hong Kong and things like that.
They're like, how do we trust Huckabee to
go back home? Huckabee do some of that stuff.
They help us.
Well, it doesn't seem that Taiwan and Hong
Kong are the ones potentially being dishonest,
though, right? I mean, it's in that sense,
it's not a concern.
Oh, yeah. But they're they're like, if the
world over division is not looking out for
us, then how do we know what's actually true?
What's happening?
Fair enough. Yeah, no, that's definitely concern.
When I saw that video, it was extraordinarily
disturbing and makes me question question
the Chinese data. And listen, I mean, when
we look at data, we should probably just not
even look at China like let's just exclude
China when we look at growth rates, when we
look at mitigation. You know, look at South
Korea as a successful example. Look at Taiwan.
Look at some other places. I don't know how
much of an advantage there is to even including
China in the data at this point. Like we know
what needs to be done. We know what can be
done. China's numbers we may never really
know is where I am at this point.
Oh, yeah. Well, thank you so much for your
time. All right, thank you for the call. Let's
take a quick break. We will go right back
to the phones after the break. So if you are
holding, don't hang up because we are getting
right back to phone calls momentarily